hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
very early on in all things are possible
lev chesterf is going to speak of the
law of sequence in natural
phenomena and that is sort of a stand-in
for causality one of the things that
modern philosophy well actually
philosophy in general since the
ancient time but particularly in modern
philosophy they were concerned about is
causality
as an issue and we see this for example
in david hume and his considerations of
cause and effect
and then in kant who's responding to
hume and so many
other thinkers as well and chest off
he's not saying that there aren't causes
and effects but he is thinking
that things are quite a bit more complex
than we take them to to be at one point
he says that
generally when there's some sort of
thing that we observe it's a bunch of
different causes coming together and we
pick out the one that's
to us the most obvious and then thereby
get things wrong
in the very beginning of all things are
possible
he's got a very interesting discussion
of this law
of sequence of things following each
other in regular
order and he says it seems so plausible
so obvious that we're tempted to look
for its origin
not in the realities of actual life but
in the promptings of the human mind
this is the idea that causality is in
some way
ah priori it's it's a necessary way in
which we
see the universe in front of us and the
experiences that we
undergo and how we connect them together
and then he says this law of sequence is
actually the most mysterious of all the
natural laws
why so much order why not chaos and
disorderliness
really if the hypothesis of sequence had
not offered such
blatant advantages to the human
intelligence man would never have
thought of raising it to the rank of
eternal and irrefutable truth but he saw
his
opportunity so what he's saying here is
that
you know if you think about things
there's really no no fundamental
grounding reason
why things actually have to work in
regular order and succession
you can come up with reasonings about
that as people have done throughout the
ages
but a lot of that is based on our
willingness to buy into that
or our need for things to be regular
like that or it's drawing conclusions
from our experience which is never
vast enough to really draw many
conclusions from
and so he goes on and he says thanks to
this grand hypothesis
man is forewarned and forearmed thanks
to this master key the future is
at his mercy he knows in order that he
may foreign right
and so this is one grand motif in why
we're so
into causality it lets us feel
like the future is in some degree in our
hands
determined we can count on it now
is that always the case it's the case
sometimes but there's so many other
things
that can come along and disrupt matters
he also says that here is man by virtue
of one supreme assumption dictator
henceforth of all nature and then he
says philosophers
have ever bowed the knee to success so
down they went before the newly invented
law of natural sequence
and they hailed it with the title of
eternal truth so that was
that was in his view kind of a mistake
going
beyond what they ought to have done but
understandable because philosophers like
other human beings like what seems to be
successful and if we look at the history
of philosophy we see all sorts of ideas
adopted throughout the ages even down to
the present which are much more
you could say convenient or
satisfying emotional needs than
necessarily true or they're just part of
the general
culture and so this helps to explain
why we're so big on this and
you know it's interesting he follows
this up with with the thing in in
chapter three says the comfortable
settled person says to themselves how
could one live without being sure of the
morrow
how could one sleep without a roof over
one's head so this is like a
way of being you know that has a regular
sequence and then he says
then miss fortune turns him out of house
and home he has to sleep under her head
she cannot rest he's full of terrors
there may be wild beasts fellow tramps
but in the long run he gets used to it
he will trust himself to chance
live like a [ __ ] and sleep his sleep in
the ditch so there's you know
we often make the mistake of thinking
like we've figured out
the way things have to be you know
following sort of regular laws and rules
and stuff like that and turns out that's
not the case at all
we can adapt ourselves to all sorts of
things he has some other discussions
about this
a little bit later on this is in part
2 chapter 16
and he says that this is a certain thing
that happens at certain times of life
although other people could get jaded
earlier or later
a man comes to the past where all
experience seems exhausted
wherever he go whatever he see all is
old and wearingly
familiar most people explain this by
saying that they really know everything
and that from what they have experienced
they can infer all
experience so this is a very common
mistake and it's made pretty much in
every culture and every every time we
can see
all sorts of examples of this throughout
the history of human beings
we might even have experienced it
ourself or
in those who we know they think it's
just repetition it's all the same we've
got it finally
figured out again sequence consequence
causality you understand
the causes and effects of things he says
this this
phase of the exhaustion of life usually
comes to a man between 35 and 40
not seeing anything new the individual
assumes he's completely matured and has
the right to judge of
everything knowing what has been he can
forecast
what will be and
chest off calls this a spiritual
stagnation
and he says you shouldn't take this
spiritual stagnation
as a sort of ratification
first of all that you've actually got it
right and that you can judge
all of life's possibilities from the
known
possibilities because your range of what
you've actually
seen is actually going to be quite small
and he says
on the contrary however rich and
multifarious the past may have been it's
not exhausted a little bit
the whole of the possibilities from that
which has been
it is impossible to infer what will be
so this is a denial of anything like
strict causality at least in human
affairs
knowing the past knowing the present
having had experiences
is not enough to tell you how things are
going to be in the future
we might think about our own time and
the massive transformations
that we've undergone ourselves and he
says that
um it's also unnecessary except perhaps
to give us a sense of our
full maturity and let us enjoy the
charms of the best period of life
this temptation is not overwhelming so
if you're under the necessity
even during a period of arrest and
stagnation and until such
time as life restarts being doomed to
meditation
would it not be better to use this
meditating
interregnum for a directly opposite
purpose for finding in our past
signs which tell us that the future has
every right to be anything whatsoever
like or unlike the past and so then he
goes on and he
he actually starts drawing conclusions
not just about human affairs he says
at times one comes to the conclusion
that the natural connection of phenomena
as hitherto observed is not at all
inevitable for the future
and miracles which so far seemed
impossible may come to seem possible
even natural far more natural
than that law that loathsome law of
sequence
the law of the regularity of phenomena
so this is a possibility for us we don't
have to sort of bend the knee to what
has been hitherto the success
of the law of sequence of phenomena
things could be different things have
been different
people get surprised all the time and
it's not just because they didn't
understand all the factors
nobody understands all the factors right
and here he says something else that i
think is quite interesting he says
we're bored stiff with regularity and
sequence confess it
you also men of science you
also the people who are pushing this
point of view that we've got it all
figured out
it's just a matter of sort of like
filling in the boxes and drawing the
proper lines
you're bored with this too this is a
very important existential theme
the idea that the introduction of lots
and lots of rationality
and regularity into life actually
stifles us
and he says that at the mere thought
that however we may think you can get no
further than the acknowledgement of the
old regularity
an invincible disgust to any kind of
mental work
overcomes us we want
more out of life than that and he says
to discover another law when already we
have far more than we can do with
surely if there's any will to think left
in us it is established in the
supposition that the mind cannot and
must not have any bounds
any limits and so we see this this
constantly happening within the history
of ideas
and of human beings and culture
themselves
every bit somebody's got it all figured
out you have this regularity and then
boom things come along and that cracks
open and we discover
new ways of doing things and you might
actually i mean you can also
turn this by the way in our own time
into its own sort of law of regularity
we're going to like figure out
innovation and disruption
we always have to be at the cutting edge
those people are just as boring
as the people who are stuck in the mud
back here who are like regularity
regularity irregularity
because they all say the same damn thing
over and over and over again right
the same buzzwords the same laws that
they think they figured out
so interestingly in our time even the
people who are stressing like
uh you know being yourself and you know
being a disruptor or something like that
they're just as
as tied to this as anybody else and you
can see that by the appeals that they'll
often make when they get pushed
to like neuroscience or other things
that are supposed to be
determining regularity and helping us
understand things
he also talks about this to some degree
in
chapter 1 part 1 chapter
33. says the possibilities which open
out before mankind are sufficiently
limited it's impossible
to see everything impossible to know
everything impossible to rise too high
above the earth
impossible to penetrate too deeply down
we're always stuck
not knowing more things than we know
and we don't even know how much we don't
know
so he says regularity immutably regular
succession of phenomena puts a term to
our efforts
drives us into a regular narrow hard
beaten road of everyday life
even on this road we may not wander from
side to side we must watch our feet
consider each step
since the moment we're off our guard
danger the disaster is upon us
and so you know regularity it's kind of
funny because
we're being you know we're experiencing
it we're
having it pushed upon us and yet it's
not enough to compel us
we have to be careful to make sure that
we stay regular
right we have to stay on the road even
though the road has long been
established for us why well he goes on
and he says
another life is conceivable life in
which in which the word disaster does
not exist where the responsibility for
one's actions even if it's not
completely abolished at least as not
such a deadly and accidental weight
and where on the other hand there is no
regularity but an
infinite number of possibilities
there's always possibilities that are
not being realized
and we could we could grab them even if
it seems to violate the law of
succession
which shows us that the law of
succession is not such a strict
eternal immutable law as it's being
portrayed
the bold and the timid sometimes
accidentally stumbling stumbling into it
often
discover this there's another
place where he's talking about this and
i like to call it the parable of the
pike it's actually my favorite passage
of this work he begins it
by track he titles this this section
on method and he says
there's an experiment a glass jar is
divided into two halves by a
glass partition on the one side of the
partition so we're thinking about a huge
fish tank right
he places a pike so if you don't know
what a pike is
it's a predatory fish that exists
in europe in in asia and in north
america
the muscalunge is an example that we
have here we have the northern pike
and then there's the hammer pike and the
pickerel and they have
mouths that are full of teeth generally
dripping with anticoagulants so if you
get bitten by one it's a bad bite
and they are aggressive because of their
shape when they actually start swimming
at fish
they can go up to like 20 miles an hour
for very brief bursts under the water
and they're hunters who like to
hang out and then when they see
something they go out and they get it
and it can be another fish
it can even be another pike it can be
ducklings
it can be all sorts of things and so
you've got a pike and then you've got
these other small
fish that would be the pike's prey the
pike doesn't notice the partition
and it it goes to try to get the fish
and it bumps into the glass and it hurts
its nose
and it does this over and over and over
again and after a while
the pike stops going after the fish
it realizes there's a invisible
partition there that is going to cause
pain for it then they pull the partition
up
now what do you think happens the pike
has learned a lesson
if i go after these fish it hurts my
nose
i'm not going to do that and he says at
last seeing its efforts ending so
painfully it abandoned the hunt
when the partition had been removed it
continued to swim about the small fry
without daring to attack them
shestop says does not the same happen
with us with our experience with
being told that this is the way things
are perhaps the limits between this
world and the other world are also
essentially of an experimental origin
not rooted in the nature of things as
was thought before kant
or in the nature of our reason as
thought after [ __ ]
maybe a partition does exist and makes
vane all attempts to cross over
but maybe there's a moment where this
partition is removed
in our minds we've already got the
conviction
rooted that it's impossible to pass
certain limits and painful to try a
conviction
formed on experience and then he
suggests
in this case we should return to david
hume's old skepticism
david hume said first of all that
causality didn't really exist as such
and then he also said that
if we can imagine things differently
they could be differently
there's a possibility we can't say with
necessity
that anything experiential must be the
way it is
and he says the most lasting and varied
experience cannot lead to any binding
and universal conclusion are ah priori
which are so useful for a certain time
becomes sooner or later extremely
harmful a philosopher should not be
afraid of skepticism
but should go on bruising his jaw
isn't that an interesting idea to be a
genuine philosopher
would mean continuing to experiment
continuing to try to
figure things out and going against this
law
these laws that say oh it could only be
this way we've figured out the causes
of things and this is indeed why
philosophers
are so often you know irritating and
unwelcome
among people in the other disciplines
because people in the other disciplines
we've figured things out
psychology we we know you know how
rewards and punishments affect people so
when it comes to this or that we're you
know we're going to arrange it and it'll
all work out and then the philosopher
comes along and says
oh interesting assumptions there are you
sure about that
what if we tried doing this or let's
just do a thought experiment and then
they're like
shut up get out of here we're already
done with the
figuring things out so the parable of
the pike is
is quite powerful i'd say um the other
thing that's that's very interesting in
this book is that shestop
also talks about this as how it applies
to
thinkers writers and perspectives like
philosophical perspectives
on things and he's got this amazing
discussion which is completely as far as
i can tell correct
about masters and disciples
and ideas in the realm of ideas we often
apply
something like a law of causality you
say well you know somebody
had these things going on at the time
therefore this is why their philosophy
looks the way it is
and then we also do this with well you
know
spinoza was a cartesian as a good
cartesian he must have thought this
and then he went on and added these
things and so this is what he calls
theories of sequence and consequence and
he says these are binding only on
disciples
not upon the masters why
fathers of great ideas tend to be
careless about their progeny
giving very little heed to their future
career the offspring of one in the same
philosopher
frequently bears small such small
resemblance to one another
it's impossible to discern the family
connection
fertile productive minds are like drawn
in a million different directions
and doing lots of different things so
you think about plato for example right
plato is both a disciple
and a master and actually insofar as
he's
a disciple of socrates he's doing stuff
that kind of follows from what socrates
is doing
and then he brings in all sorts of ideas
of his own
and you know weaves them into these
amazing dialogues
which as nietzsche recognized are a new
genre
uh practically speaking and you know
nietzsche saw it as sort of you know a
way of cobbling together the shipwreck
of the previous
ways of of doing literature um
[Music]
plato didn't actually consult anybody
and say well how should i be doing
things
how should i write my dialogues should i
write dialogues or should i write
academic papers published in a
peer-reviewed journal
with you know reviewer one and reviewer
two or something no he didn't do
anything like that
and then you know we have followers and
oftentimes followers are you know
doing interesting things expanding uh
the
the scope great example of this is
aristotle's good friend theo frastus
who was traveled with him helped found
the lyceum
carried through some of aristotle's
massive research projects
but doesn't appear to have been a
particularly original thinker whereas
aristotle was
right so he says that conscientious
disciples wasting away under the arduous
effort to discover what doesn't exist or
brought to despair of their task
having got an inkling of the truth
concerning their difficulties
they give up the job forever they cease
their attempt at reconciling glaring
contradictions
but then they insist the only the harder
on the necessity of studying the
philosophers
studying them minutely circumstantially
historically
philologically even so the history of
philosophy is born which is now he says
taking
the place of history and so we have
people who can tell you all about
you know almost this is a facetious
example what what
hegel ate on this morning over here but
they can't actually
do hegel they're they're sort of cut off
from the spirit of hegel's great work
very often some of the best commentators
on philosophers are not the ones who
like
get it all right about the past but who
sees on the
vital experience of that that
philosopher's
ideas and what it's like to think the
world through their sometimes
contradictory
lenses and so disciples are very
different than masters we can
we can say that disciples actually do
follow and
impose the law of sequence and
consequence
um he says for a good translation or a
commentary on the chief works of can
on kant a man may be given the degree of
doctor of philosophy
and here henceforth recognizes one who's
initiated in the profundities of the
secret of the universe right
but kant is something different than
that reading kant is
is if you actually understand what
you're reading an experience of great
depth
it might be wrong about some stuff but
you're like wow this guy is thinking
some thoughts
right reading secondary literature on
kant
doesn't really have that experience and
if all you do by the way is read the
secondary literature
or intro tax or textbooks or stuff like
that
and you don't read the actual
philosophers well you're really missing
out on something
same as you would be if you don't read
dostoevsky but only read cliff's notes
or whatever other you know digests of
that you you can do
the last thing that he talks about with
this um ronald thinkers is
he's he's actually praising the kids of
his time
this is in part 2
chapter 35 and he says that
people are jumping from perspective to
perspective he talks about this in terms
of evolution right and he says in recent
years we see more and more
change in the philosophies of writers
and even non-literary people
the old men are beside themselves such
shiftiness seems indifferent
convictions are not gloves right you put
one on take one off
but the young carelessly pass on from
one idea to
another people announce how far they are
now from the beliefs they held six
months ago
one even publishes volumes relating how
you pass from one philosophy to another
into a third
people see nothing alarming in that kind
of evolution they believe it's all in
the ordering of things
and you know you could look at that as
like the law of succession again right
and chester says nah there's something
else going on here
an awareness of the fact that it's us
who decides whether we want to
adopt a philosophical perspective or not
that's up to us
we get to choose and so he says
um to those of us
who fought so long against all kinds of
constancy
the levity of the young is a pleasant
sight they will dawn materialism
positives and conscientism spiritualism
and so on one after another until they
realize that all theories ideas and
ideals
are as of little consequence as the hoop
skirts and crinolines of our
grandmothers
and so living without being confined by
the law of sequence within the realm of
ideas
is something that shestow thinks uh can
be quite useful i mean it might also
turn a person into a
superficial dilettante quite true who
treats philosophies essentially
as cultural products to swap out for
each other but
it also opens up the possibility of you
know to go back to the parable of the
pike
going beyond the partition if the
partition has been removed
and so we shouldn't be great believers
or trusters
in the laws of regular succession
we could we could say well everything
i'm observing tells me
that things you know succeed each other
and when i drop this piece of chalk it's
going to fall
but things could be different things
could always go otherwise and
particularly when we're thinking about
human affairs in the world of ideas
this notion of strict causality and
sequence is probably more and more
restrictive and out of place
you